time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week we begin
with a study that looked at the safety
of drugs and therapies that are
classified as novel these are drugs and
products that are considered by the fda
to be innovative medications that either
serve unmet medical needs or
significantly help to advance patient
care and health the study looked at
approvals from 2001 to 2010 examining
222 drugs 71 of these about a third
ended up producing some sort of post
market safety incident it took an
average of around four years from the
time of approval to the first incident
being reported CBS new chief medical
correspondent dr. Jon LaPook and CBS
News contributor dr. Tara and a ruler
are here to talk to us about this John
to start with what type of actions were
taken and and when were the safety
concerns what were the safety concerns
with these drugs well first of all Tara
and I were both impressed at the
beginning of this just for perspective
beginning of the article they said that
most pivotal trials that form the basis
for these approvals involved fewer than
a thousand people for six months or less
which is this it's not very much not
very long so you would say you can see
why you it's so important to have the
post-marketing surveillance right keep
looking at after it gets approved of the
problems that they had there were three
that were actually withdrawn for the
market two were for cardiovascular
problems one was for a neurological
problem there was 61 black boxes you
know what that is when they put the
black box warning it says you know
there's really a problem and then there
were 59 safety communications in Tara
with the drugs that they looked at were
there any trends when it came to safety
there were a few trends they found that
biologic drugs so those that are made
from living cells as opposed to
chemicals seem to have more of these
incidents in addition drugs that were
designed for psychiatric diseases or
disorders and then in terms of approval
and how they were approved those drugs
that were nearing the end of meeting
their deadline for approval tended to
have more incidents as well as drugs
that were under the accelerated approval
track and when we talk about that we're
saying for example when you're looking
at trials or research and you're
typically approving a drug you might
look for did it improve survival when
it's in the accelerated track you're
looking at what we call
surrogate endpoints meaning did it
shrink a tumor size as opposed it did it
improve survival so in all of these four
areas that's where we saw more of the
incidents II John I mean there's this
ongoing debate John about how do you how
do you balance the whole idea of getting
these drugs in the hands of people
quickly versus you know ensuring safety
standards so where does the medical
community come down on this it is really
tough right on the one hand you end get
that drug soon especially if you have a
problem that it could treat on the other
hand you want to be safe and this has
been a real yin-yang and a lot of
friction in the medical community about
this the US Government Accountability
Office had a report about 18 months ago
and today I spoke to them just recently
if they feel the same way that they
think that if you have a process where
something's being accelerated in terms
of how quickly there's a flame lit under
it it's getting approved a little more
quickly than normal they think that then
post-market after it's approved you
should be looking at it more closely and
just to see you know anything going on
the FDA says look we have we look at
everything closely yeah and so we're not
they we're not looking at that
particularly more closely than anything
else so it's really really tough I mean
I think that dr. Scott Gottlieb the new
head of the FDA is going to have you
know a lot of issues on his hand trying
to figure out do you accelerate this and
if you do how do you do with in the
safest way possible the sweet spot yeah
it's easier said than done
type of thing our next topic is going to
deal with something that many people may
be guilty of using me this morning
cotton swabs to clean the inside of our
ears it can be hazardous for us and our
children a recently published study in
the Journal of Pediatrics examined
Hospital data for children 18 and
younger over a 20-year period it found
that an estimated two hundred
sixty-three thousand children were
treated for ear injuries related to
using cotton tip applicators that
equates to about 34 kids a day 73
percent of the injuries occurred due to
ear cleaning before you scold me let's
talk about the kids here there there are
a lot of kids in the study or some of
the trends that we saw there yes it's
tempting to want to go in there when you
get in your child but don't do it don't
do it two out of three of these injuries
were in kids who are under the age of
eight well and in fact
the number and rate seemed to peak in
terms of injury around the age of two
and then decline through the rest of
adolescence and when they looked at who
was holding the cotton tip applicator
and 77% of the time it was the child
themselves but 16 percent of time it was
actually the parent so in terms of the
diagnosis that people were getting when
they got to the ER some of it was
foreign body sensation
some of it was bleeding or actual
rupture to the tympanic membrane in the
ear or soft tissue injury so while they
say that 99 percent of these can be
treated easily and discharged from the
ER there can be long-term ramifications
if you actually damage the inner ear you
can cause your child in the future to
end up having problems with dizziness
balance or even hearing loss well and
obviously adults use these things too I
mean so what mean what is the proper way
to use them well firstly you should just
realize that maybe you don't have to do
anything because the ear is a
self-cleaning oven right and the wax is
actually serving a purpose its its
lubricating it actually has some
antibacterial properties and generally
it goes out on its own if you do need to
put something in there you know you can
have a cloth on the outside there are
some drops you can put in or in some
irrigation solutions but you definitely
don't want to take a solid object and
Ram it in your ear think of like you
know a musket how did you do it like
that I promise you can go to your doctor
I've had this happen when I had some ear
wax that was really embedded in there
and there's a little device they put in
it goes that sucks it out it's a
greatest feeling in the world when that
comes out but don't do it on your own
and some of it is teaching kids not to
play with it because some of these
injuries were actually playing with the
q-tips running with them tripping and
falling so keep them away from kids put
things up their nose in the raises most
often here again pen caps new
all right finally technology that could
relieve some patients of the burden of
taking daily medications research
published in the journal Nature
biomedical engineering looks at a system
developed by a team at Stanford that can
monitor and maintain levels of drugs in
the bloodstream
the personalized drug delivery tool
includes the use of a bio sensor that
contract drug levels in real-time a
control system that figures out the
dosing and a pump that delivers the
medicine in the proper levels the
developers hope to make the system
smaller so it can be implanted or worn
by a patient it's only been tested in
animals at this point and many years of
testing are probably still ahead to make
it make sure it's safe for people but it
sounds really interesting it makes
perfect sense right somebody needs
antibiotics we say 500 milligrams four
times a day doesn't mean if you're big
small large doesn't matter and with
cardiac drugs so important to get the
dose right because when you're off under
or over it makes a big difference so yes
I think this push towards tailored
personalized medicine would be wonderful
way to go all right
doctors Jon LaPook dr. Tara Narula thank
you very much